une ville considérée comme l'une des
plus romantiques de la planète
victime de son succès la sérénissime et
maintenant submergé par les touristes
[Musique]
en douze mois venise accueille plus de
30 millions de visiteurs
c'est un nombre qui ne cesse d'augmenter
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya plus de 500
touristes pour chaque résident c'est un
peu comme si à montréal on accueillait
plus d'un milliard de personnes en une
seule année
venise est bien sûr unique mais elle
n'est pas la seule à être envahi la
vague touristique frappe tous les
continents
c'est une industrie qui vaut 10 % de la
richesse générée sur la planète
[Musique]
plusieurs facteurs expliquent ce boom
d'abord il n'a jamais été aussi
abordable de voyager loin en avion de
plus en plus de visiteurs viennent de
pays émergents et puis il y à internet
l'accès aux cartes et aux
recommandations facilite les voyages à
l'étranger et toutes ces photos que nous
affichons d'un des idées à nos amis en
2019 le tourisme de masse n'apporte pas
que des dollars il apporte également son
lot de complications
par exemple il ya tellement de gens que
se déplacer trouvé son cliché ou encore
un endroit pour se reposer devienne une
sorte de parcours du combattant
et bien sûr le tourisme de masse
polluent il y à tous ces déchets que
venise peine à ramasser et c'est sans
compter les gaz à effet de serre
produits pour venir jusqu'ici et à
venise les touristes chasse les
résidents de nombreux appartements ont
été transformés pour loger des touristes
qui paient plus cher
les boulangers ont fait place aux
vendeurs gelato pour protéger les
trésors de venise les autorités ont fait
quelques pas d'abord ces gros navires ne
pourront plus circuler aussi près du
centre historique
et puis pour voir venise les visiteurs
devront payer
[Musique]
venise a également décidé de sévir
contre des comportements jugés
inappropriés comme se baigner dans le
canal ou encore s'asseoir dans les
escaliers mais tout ça ce n'est pas qu'à
venise beaucoup de villes doivent
maintenant résoudre le casse-tête du
tourisme de masse autour des lieux les
plus populaires les infrastructures sont
débordés chaque jour il faut du temps et
de l'énergie pour effacer les traces du
passage des touristes même les pelouses
n'en peuvent plus certains musées ont
maintenant des difficultés pour bien
accueillir des foules record ici trente
mille personnes viennent chaque jour
dans l'espoir d'apercevoir un portrait
au sourire énigmatique et parfois ces
foules déborde dans des petites rues
paisibles les touristes deviennent alors
des envahisseurs qu'on ne veut plus
accueillir dans son quartier autant de
signes qu'il y a trop de visiteurs au
même endroit et qu'il faut faire quelque
chose
à certains endroits les responsables ont
décidé de limiter le nombre de visiteurs
d'autres imposent des limites à la
location d'appartements de courte durée
ailleurs on imagine des circuits
touristiques alternatifs afin de mieux
répartir la masse de visiteurs
évidemment il n'est pas question
d'interdire le tourisme qui est
d'ailleurs en pleine expansion et c'est
peut-être là l'ironie il y à peu
d'endroits sur la planète ou les dollars
des visiteurs ne seront pas les
bienvenus